use the podcast for business development
so the guests that you have coming on
are potential referral partners for you
so that they know you like you trust you
they will send business to you and if
you brought on 10 guests and you get one
two three people out of the ten actually
send you clients afterwards because they
love you and what you can provide most
people bring on their competitors or
people in their industry which is a fun
conversation that leads to zero business
and so that little ship is how you can
take a brand new podcast like Mina's
creating here and start actually making
some real money off of it and the focus
becomes selling your thing for 500 to
2500 packages instead of trying to sell
her book or affiliate marketing or these
things that will be little dollars
instead of the big dollars the thing
with affiliate marketing is you need to
have real volume to make it work the
commission rate is usually pretty low
and the volume off of first sale is
usually pretty low problem with
affiliate marketing is you need you need
lots of scale to make it work like
everybody's trying to go through the
front door and so it has the most
resistance sense it's the hardest to get
through so you climb through a window
and you find another way
the whole conversation is very
ideas about how to
grow my with my podcast I was contacted
with two companies
one it's about supplements to promote
that product on my podcast
and the other it's activewear
for sports
okay the problem is when it's mentioned
that I'm in France may I can't apply
well okay so listen so for people
watching you know the strategy was if
you're gonna host a podcast bring on
people that can be business development
for you so that it's not just other
coaches or other people in your industry
it's people who could potentially refer
you clients and Mina went on an amazing
Health Journey how much weight did you
lose seven kilograms seven kilograms I
don't know what that is in pounds I
think pounds but yeah but she went back
to you went back to your University wait
and then you've kept it off like this
I'll I'll you know since then
yes more than 15 years now I keep the
same baby shape yeah and so she teaches
other people how they can do it as well
and the idea with the podcast was okay
what are some of the companies that if
they knew who you were would potentially
introduce you to clients so uh first up
great like congrats on on reaching out
to two companies and start to make some
some progress and traction there uh the
two things I would look at is one more
you know more if you only have two
companies then it's really like oh my
gosh I have to make this work
versus if you had a hundred that you're
reaching out to now it's not as it
doesn't it doesn't matter as much like
if one company is slow or one company
says no or one company you knows doesn't
respond or whatever right
um so I think we do this a lot because
we put so much pressure on like this one
thing having to work and then if it
doesn't it all falls apart where we just
need just more volume so two is great
two is better than zero and now we need
you know 98 more to go reach out to and
see whether it might be a fit uh and
then two
when when uh when the front door is
closed and the back door is closed you
go through the window
you know so if they're if their their
process is you fill out this form oh
you're from France you can't apply okay
that that's the front door
so what's the windows you know it might
just be I don't know how big the company
is but it might be finding who the CEO
is and messaging her on Instagram or on
Twitter or if it's a really big company
maybe it's the the VP of marketing
there's somebody in marketing and
messaging her on Instagram or on Twitter
right just like okay we have this path
and it's often not usually the path that
like everybody's trying to go to the
front door and so it has the most
resistance
it's the hardest to get through
so you climb through a window and you
find another way through to make it work
so that company that you like both of
them could be fits and if they're saying
no or they're not you know they have a
web form and because you're in France
they're saying you know you can't apply
cool
you reach out and find another way and
say hey I'd love to have you as a guest
on my podcast and share your story
that's a good idea
yeah even even in that like even the
whole idea of having a show
to do business development is already
going through the window and set it
through the front door because
whether it's the activewear company or
was a supplement company that you're
talking to uh they get hit up all the
time with people trying to make deals
trying to do Partnerships uh so you're
one of many people trying to reach out
but they don't get connected with enough
with people who want to share their
story
they don't get a lot of interview
requests so that becomes a path you're
going through as media now instead of
just the usual path as a partner and
it's easier to get a yes to come on your
show and tell their story
yes so the good news uh is that I
created my YouTube channel let's go Mina
this is great
it's not
um active yet but it will be soon so it
will be on the same topic and the
interviews I did for the podcast I will
meet them on my YouTube channel
okay great I'm thinking about affiliate
marketing to inter introduce in
in the description of videos
so you can the thing with affiliate
marketing is you need to have
real volume to make it work if you look
at coaching for example like how much is
your you have a bunch of programs but
what are the price ranges for your
programs to work with you
the first uh
offer it will be 497 dollars okay
and what's the highest offer that you
have what's the price
2 for
497. okay so every person who comes in
uh that you're gonna start working with
is either basically 500 or 2500 that's
good like that's um that's some good
money for people coming in if you go to
affiliate marketing
if you look at you know let's take
activewear and let's take supplements
which are the two companies that you're
talking to and you can go to you can go
to books it can go to other things as
well too but the commission rate is
usually pretty low
and the volume off of first sale is
usually pretty low
and so you might make the problem with
affiliate marketing is you need you need
lots of scale to make it work so
you know let's say even in a generous
case like if one in a hundred people
that's very generous right would like
click and buy something from it from
your YouTube video so you have you know
one person and how much you're gonna
make five bucks off of a off of a
commission ten dollars off of the
commission like it's it's not a lot of
money off of each one compared to
if somebody signs up for your program
and now you're making 500 or or twenty
five hundred dollars so it's not it's
not bad to have it could add a little
bit of a bonus I guess if you're putting
it in the description below but most
people don't read the description unless
you call it out in the video like if you
made a video about the supplement or the
activewear or something then you'll have
a much higher percentage of people
clicking through otherwise people don't
really look at the description
um so there's nothing wrong with doing
it it's just probably not going to make
you that much money and if you had a
choice between where you spend your
energy you want to spend it on the
things that will have the highest return
now if you had a million people watching
your videos then affiliate marketing
makes a whole lot more sense right uh
because because those ten dollars and
five dollars start to really add up but
at the beginning when you have you know
you just started the channel you have no
videos yet but it's coming but the best
thing to sell is you so it's your your
your training your coaching your 500 or
2500 packages that's where most of the
effort should be a lot of work to do
well here's the thing is like it's it's
also trying to make it easier so it's
not as much work right so the whole idea
of affiliate marketing makes more work
for you because now you got to find the
companies you've got to find the links
you gotta update the description you got
to sign their agreement see it like this
it's work to do all the affiliate
marketing stuff with at the beginning
very little results
so I wouldn't worry about it
so like if you're if you're overwhelmed
by work and lots of things to do
no not really because I'm consistent uh
on doing it the only thing that I'm not
consistent is showing up and markets my
podcast and this is my big challenge is
to show up on Facebook on Instagram on
Tech talk uh but I'm planning to show up
minimum twice a week
so as to start to go there and to talk
about my podcast so that'll be a better
use of your time
because if yeah if the goal of the
podcast is you're going to bring on
people who if they knew who you were
leads the business for you so you're
going to bring on a supplement company
entrepreneur or a fashion wear or
sportswear entrepreneur or whoever else
that relates to your industry if if the
supplement company entrepreneur loves
you and loves your story and you love
their products
they don't sell coaching
they sell supplements no so could they
sell coaching could they refer you to
some of their clients could you work it
out that
sure somebody's buying supplements but
maybe they're not consistently buying
supplements because they don't have a
program that they're on they need
someone like you to come in and give
them a program
and help them figure out even what
supplements to be on and for how long
so if the goal of having a podcast is to
bring on people like that who then if
you had 10 people on one two three of
them start referring you to their
clients
and then every client you bring on
that's 500 each or 2500 each or
somewhere in there right so if if you
interviewed if you interview 10 people
who are all potential ideal fits for you
and three of them refer people on to you
or send an email out talking about you
uh and then out of that you get
40 people who sign up for your program
you know that's a lot more than you'd
make off of affiliate marketing right so
it's uh spending the effort on
getting booking the people so doing the
Outreach so you've done two amazing
that's a great start now it's like how
do we get it to 100 and then extra time
would be working on promoting the
podcast making content doing clips for
Instagram and YouTube shorts Etc
um
that's where I put extra effort in
because the bigger the podcast gets the
easier it's going to be to get people on
your show to say yes
yeah and the last such a day I
participated in um Summit Health Summit
and it was organized by different
coaches and I was invited to talk about
my story
and it was interesting because we
decided to do challenges from time to
time and to talk and each one market all
the other coaches
so it's a manner to talk about my
podcast as well
yeah the thing with those challenges is
seeing that there's a lead anywhere you
know so you did one one is just a great
experience because the more you get a
chance to talk about your story the
better and and you'll get better at it
every time you tell the story you get
better and you get better and you get
better and you get better being a part
of a summit is great because there's
there's a live audience and there's also
a replay audience
um the model is usually
let's have all of the people come on
then email their lists and everybody
brings a few people or however many
people and create this Summit it really
just depends on who's in there and how
big their lists are
to see how many people actually show up
um but in that that model can work one
just to get the experience and then two
you're thinking does this
is it helping me get business
so at the beginning it might even not
matter if you get business or not from
it because you're telling your story
you're practicing in front of a new
audience building a relationship with
the other coaches may not be as valuable
because they're they're selling the same
thing as you maybe not the exact same
thing but close and what exactly the
same thing for example one is
um keto diet another one is essential
oil for example specialized in essential
oil and each one has her business so
it's different from my Approach right so
but your approach is very nutrition
heavy right it's a holistic program a
holistic approach
um Nutrition Fitness and mind body heart
soul everybody has their own modality
and that's great
if somebody's going to hire somebody
right if you think about somebody coming
to the summit who's trying to learn and
they're going to then work with somebody
would they work with both you and the
keto person at the same time
I don't like maybe but probably not
but would they work with you and the
essential oils person at the same time
Maybe
maybe yeah maybe but but that's that's
the kind of thing of like okay they're
not they're not direct competitors and I
don't really see like competition like
that but it's more if somebody's coming
on it's like who you can develop a
business relationship with you want like
with the keto person ever refer business
to you
I don't think so probably not right so
so
so
nurturing that relationship is probably
not strategically a good decision if you
just love that person and you share
entrepreneurial advice and it's great
being around other people it's a
different benefit it's more of like you
have a connection Circle and people that
bounce ideas off of cool but it's not
it's not going to generate business for
you
because you're you're too close even
though your thing is more holistic and
keto might be part of it I'm not part of
it but like the keto woman is not going
to refer business to you probably so the
essential oils person maybe like that's
a probably a closer fit because you
might talk a little bit about essential
oils but it's only like a little piece
of the whole thing because Fitness and
Nutrition is going to be a lot bigger
piece
same thing with anybody who's coming on
and doing a fitness program
would they ever refer clients to you
so again if you just love that person
and you want to you want to make the
relationship is something else it's just
because you love that entrepreneur and
you love hanging out with them cool but
it's not going to lead to business for
you
so that's what in thinking of these
summits
just to tell your story and just to
practice and just getting your message
out there that's a win especially right
now when you're
at the start of sharing all this stuff
so that's great that's amazing
ongoing though you need to start asking
yourself one did I get business from
this event
and two do the do the people here who
are also speaking is there a connection
for me that can help me grow my business
and if too many people are like you and
they won't give you business and you
probably wouldn't pass them on like
you're probably not giving business to
the keto person unless somebody says
Mina like I only want to do keto and I
don't want the holistic thing then you
might say okay well here's go to this
person because I can't help you but
you're probably not referring too many
people to the keto person either where
something like the supplement company or
something like the athletic wear company
or or products around it they're not in
coaching at all
no and you're not and you're not
launching your own line of supplements
yet
yeah
right you're not building your own Nike
you know yet right which is great so
like those are much better ideal
Partnerships for you
because they can refer clients off to
you so that's just how I would evaluate
like this to tell in your store and just
getting it out there into practice which
is great but then are you getting
business from this and are the people
who are there uh potential referral
partners for you or not you make it
really clear for me because uh I was
thinking about all these things and of
course it's uh the first time and I
don't know which uh direction for now
but discussing with you it's you make it
uh really clear and digest for me cool
I'm well I'm glad to help that's that's
uh that's why we do these things that's
why we have Movie Makers too and listen
I think at the beginning it's good to
say yes to things just to just to
experiment and to test and the try and
to see and we actually did I've been a
part of a lot of those different Summits
um most recently I've said note I think
all of them
um
but we the the one we had we had one we
had a pretty good relationship and we
were actually talking about movement
makers in there and they even actually
helped promote movement makers a lot we
brought in new members through there but
then the follow-up and the accounting
and the it was actually more of a
headache for my team me I don't care I
just show up when I talk and help people
but then Nina my wife who helps like run
the company and then my team
yeah it's like it was too complicated to
work with them it created too much
hassle and too many problems to work
with them so we stopped doing that
relationship
um I love them I mean it was super fun
to do it but I'm not the only one that
matters you know if I'm making a lot
more work for my team then it doesn't
work so those are just some of the
things that you you do and you don't
know until you get into it and you try
so it's like it's great like you you try
a new food you know you taste it you see
if you like it and if you do you can go
eat some more and if you don't then you
stop so the Summits and that model is a
great thing to test to taste and try and
you're doing it if you're going to keep
like if this is going to be every month
you're going to do it now okay now it
has to it has to start the payoff it's
got to be worth it for you somehow for
your business yes it was a good exercise
to talk without slide without anything
to practice my English
and telling my story it was a good
exercise but uh of course now I have the
vision about how to grow so you make it
really clear for me if I
should continue doing this maybe for
practice okay but not thinking business
100 percent yeah and just see you know
at some point the practice will will
become less and less valuable
yes when we talk about like like today
you did one which is great there's like
learning curve you learned a lot you do
another one and you learn you still
learn but not as much another one you
learn a little bit and then by the time
you're doing your fourth or fifth one it
might be just you're not getting much
value anymore from the learning so then
is it leading to business growth for you
or not
um one thing I would do is you have a
list of all the speakers right who are
there yeah
this could be a great hack to get more
business is you look at that list
and you see who might be potential
partner for you
and then you reach out to them
and you say hey I'm Mina
we both spoke at
whatever Summit
uh I you know I was on three hours after
you so we didn't get to connect there
but I I think I'd love to learn more
about your business and have you as a
guest on my podcast
if you think it's a potential referral
partner
the essential
or a girl you contacted me yes
she sent me a message on messenger
telling me that we can connect after the
summit okay great so so I mean that's
good on her like good job for her to
reach out to you now it's on you are is
there anybody else there who might be a
potential partner for you and then you
reach out to them even if you didn't
talk to them at the event
so you look at the list of who the
speakers are going to be whether it's
this event whether it's a future event
whether it's a conference or a trade
show you look at who the list is of the
people and then who might be a potential
partner for you so you say Okay
essential oils yes he don't know you
know Fitness no apparel yes and whoever
else is on the list and then you can
send a message to them to say hey we I
saw you speaking I was a speaker there
too I'd love to have you as a guest on
my show Even if you never met them even
if you never connected at the summit you
have a point of connection which is you
are both speakers at this event
and there might be one other speaker
there besides the essential oils person
who could be a good fit for your show
that then leads to business for you as
well like if there was an apparel
company or another supplement company or
somebody else who was speaking there
you can always reach out even if you
didn't connect at the event
to have them on your show build the
relationship and hopefully get some
referrals a good idea
thank you
and so you can do that for the last one
but then also in the future for any any
ones that are coming up they usually
show their list of of speakers
um so it's an easy way to make a a great
connection as opposed to like just a
cold Instagram where they don't know who
you are yet
yeah uh I I forget but I have I was
reached by an um
platform asking me to put my podcast on
their platform I did it but I don't have
any idea about uh
uh the outcome
of it and also another app it was wisdom
app I think they asked me to to make my
my YouTube My podcast on their
platform as well
I didn't do it yet
so here's how that could be helpful for
the most part most platforms you're
probably not going to get a lot of views
or or down or playbacks on any of these
platforms
so you're not doing it because you're
going to get a million people who are
now going to listen to your podcast
because you put it on this network right
but
what you can do is at the beginning when
you're trying to build up your presence
and you're trying to attract people to
come on your show
you can use the fact that you're on
these various platforms as part of the
information about the show
so you can say
uh hey I'm CEO of some supplement
company I love your story I love to have
you come on and talk about it on my new
podcast and the podcast gets distributed
on platform platform platform platform
platform right
and so it makes it look you're using
their name
to make you look bigger than than it is
to get a yes
right so if it's just to try to gain
attention and not it's probably not
worth it because you got to figure out
their platform you got to post there you
got to sign agreement like it's just a
waste of time in terms of just getting
attention for your show
you're for the audience you want to be
on YouTube and then clips for Instagram
Tick Tock that's how you're gonna get
the audience but
if somebody went to your YouTube channel
to go there's nothing there yet
so you can say it'll be on YouTube but
it's also we have agreements which you
have to sign an agreement to get it out
to whatever podcast Network right so you
have an agreement with
worth Upworthy and whatever like five
other platforms like it's gonna go to
all these places your show with me so
it's easier to get a yes from them to
want to join that's why I would look at
it is instead of just trying to get uh
attention audience
um at the beginning of my career I did
it for media right so I went after a lot
of media Outlets who went after New York
Times we went after Wall Street Journal
we went after different media Outlets
not because like I got into New York
Times I got in the Wall Street Journal
it did zero for my business
right it's like we got mentioned in New
York Times it's not that like my
business started blowing up and now
everybody cared about me like it did it
did nothing to grow my business apart
from the fact that I can say I've been
in the New York Times
and I've been in the Wall Street Journal
it just adds more credibility
right so being a part of these other
networks you can say I'm part of
Upworthy or whatever and they have a
reach of whatever and I'm part of this
network and they have a read so it just
makes it look bigger than it is uh and
just gives you a little more credibility
coming in compared to if you didn't have
anything else that's how I would
approach those things a new in
podcasting so I'm learning I'm learning
by the woods
that's great
I think that there are a lot of things
to know to learn from doing
yeah and you're off to a great start and
again for anybody listening watching
like use the podcast for business
development so the guests that you have
coming on are potential referral
partners for you so that they know you
like you trust you they will send
business to you and if you brought on 10
guests and you get one two three people
out of the ten actually send you clients
afterwards because they love you and
what you can provide most people bring
on their competitors or people in their
industry which is a fun conversation
that leads to zero business and so that
little ship is how you can take a brand
new podcast like Mina's creating here
and start actually making some real
money off of it and the focus becomes
selling your thing for 500 to 2500
packages instead of trying to sell her
book or affiliate marketing or these
things that will be will be little
dollars instead of the big dollars
I close my business so this is what
happened a year into my first business
it wasn't working now so what I did was
I sold
I sold that one and with the money that
I made from that one I started another
one
and it was doing good
um it was a boutique a quinceanera and
Bridal Boutique I was doing really good
and then covet happened
so I had a close-up
I closed it a month ago well a month and
a half ago
I closed it and I sold the the stuff
that I had in there like um because I
didn't own the business you know just
the building itself I didn't know that I
just owned what was in there so I sold
that and I mean I took a big hit you
know I lost a lot of money on it but I
still was able to
to make some of it so that's what I'm
that money that I have right now
I don't know what to do with it because
I don't want to use it for my personal
life because what I end up doing was
going in in work so I'm working that's
whenever I was talking to you the other
day I was working
um whenever you last year yeah you're in
the store yeah
that was great I love it yeah I got in
trouble too but I was like it was an
emergency yeah but you know that's what
I end up doing having to work for
someone which is hard I mean after
you've been on your own for so long it's
hard
so right now I'm like okay what do I do
you know like I'm stuck I'm lacking
discipline
um lacking
Focus
because I have so many things going on
um
just a lot of personal stuff and then
you know business stuff
like my house my husband walked out
um in April so you know like it's like
one thing after the other I came home
one day and he was going we've been
having problems you know so this was
coming
but it's like everything here and at the
same time
I'm like what do I do you know so right
now I'm working for this place I'm still
I'm doing retail and I'm like
um manager's assistant but it's not
something that I want to do so my thing
is
um
how
can I get back into being disciplined I
mean I've always been disciplined but
right now I'm like I don't know what's
happening you know so that's where I'm
stuck okay so so you start with
yeah you take a deep breath and you
realize hey this is a this is a pretty
you've had some pretty uh life-altering
things that have happened and don't
expect to be perfect
while it's happening you know like when
I broke my neck on my tour last year
I was super frustrated too that I
couldn't do like I had a concussion
right I had a concussion broke my neck
in two spots and I'm in the hospital and
I had to cancel my event because that
was that night and then I told the
doctor okay can we can we just have
everybody who was going to come to the
event
come to my hotel and can I do something
there he's like no you have a concussion
like
can't do this right and so it was like
slowing down was really hard
um I remember that the first night I was
able to go home I couldn't
I had to go to the bathroom at you know
three or four in the morning or
something I and I pushed myself up and
and I was starting to get dizzy and I
was worried that I was gonna pass out
which isn't good when you just broken
your neck right like fall on the floor
and so I had to wake up my wife to help
me go to the bathroom and they mean that
may not seem like a big deal but I like
Independence you know I like doing my
own thing and I couldn't do something as
simple as
go to the bathroom by myself
and so it's okay that it's it you have
to go through some periods of slowness
when this stuff happens you know when I
I I'm divorced when I was divorced
I don't know eight or nine years ago
um
I I wrote to everybody who was in my
circle my customers my friends my my
employees everybody on my team and I
said hey
um here's what happened I'm not
mentally where I need to be right now
I'm not as sharp as I used to be I'm I'm
probably gonna drop a few balls
like it's not going to be as normal
evidence but I'm going to get back to it
so just letting you know this is what's
going on and and
it wasn't a total disaster
but just letting people know like it's
it's it's not even them it's it's for
you to understand that it's okay that
it's gonna slow down right now that this
is not you're not going to be in retail
forever
like in a couple years you're not going
to be working
at a retail store right and and you
deserve to have
you know a husband in your life who
supports you and believes in you and
encourages you and it's a blessing
that is gone because imagine another
four years of being with him and
just lost opportunity cost so you you
will be in a different spot so don't I
wouldn't put
so much pressure on yourself right now
and I'm the go go go consistency guy
right but there are moments where you
have to be more gentle on yourself and
not expect to be perfect on your
schedule or perfect in your discipline
um but know that you will be in a
different spot so it's now creating hope
for a better future so like where do you
where do you want to be what do you want
to be doing again like when covet's done
what do you want to be doing back to the
bridal store or something else
so I have a plan
um I'm like I'm you know I know where I
want to go like when I turn my goalie is
when I turn 50 years old
I want to have a business where I just
check up on it you know I don't want to
be involved in all this starting up and
going back and forth managing the
business I want to be able to
just check up on it you know like I tell
my my kids while they're all grown up
but you know I just want to come by
there and pick up the check and leave
you know just this is
um but what I want to do is
I want to buy some small houses and rent
them out to people with low income
because I've struggled so much while
raising my kids you know renting places
was a struggle always or just buying a
house was a struggle so I want to buy
small houses nothing big you know just
like a single home
and rent them out to people with low
income
and then like
I'm looking at two or three years
start my Bridal in quinceanera store
again
so those are the the two things that I
want to get back on you know but I just
don't know
if it's possible you know like the way I
guess the way I'm feeling right now is
just it's not helping me think but
that's really what I want to do you know
I want to start my store again in like
two to three years but come back like
with a bigger
sore because right now it was it was
small it wasn't really small but it
wasn't too big it was like a
medium-sized well one I want to come
back and make a big sword but at the
same time you know I want to be able to
buy those houses and just rent them out
why why do you believe that you can't
start a bridal store again you've
already done it you've had some success
doing it why do you believe you can't
start it up again
I'm thinking that maybe two or three
years from now
it's not going to be
um
maybe it's not going to be a big demand
like it is right now because in this
area we don't have a quinceanera we have
bridal shops but they're more
I guess my the people that I was selling
to it was more
uh Latin America you know people so it
was more of a quinceanera more than in
more than Bridal sure if I don't know if
I don't want to sound so confusing but
it wasn't a Hispanic base
you know and that's what I'm saying like
maybe in three years from now it's not
going to be such a big demand as it was
now why
um because like now what I'm seeing is
more people or
finding places or like just ordering
online and
I don't know I'm just I guess I'm just
afraid that it's not going to be a big
demand I know how to do it I mean I have
the providers I have a list you know
because I'm very
um I'm very organized when it comes to
things like that so I have all these
providers that I know I can go back to
in and purchase from but I guess I'm
just afraid that it's not going to be a
big a big demand you know what I mean
like yeah but this is the thing that you
have to this is what you have to start
getting excited by to figure out your
way through it because people can't
always buy online and that's fine but if
they're buying a wedding dress online
it's probably not your your target
audience anyway
people are coming to you for the extra
service they're coming to you for the
expert knowledge they're coming to you
for help because they don't know how to
do you're going to tell them all the
things that they need to get done that
they maybe not didn't even think about
before because you've been through it
however many times and for everybody
it's probably their first time and so
that's where people lean on an expert to
get advice and knowledge so uh the the
only problem right now is you don't
believe in that bigger future yet
which is which is what we have to
overcome because
especially the beginning of a business
when you can Target people who have
money or who are willing to pay money
it's just so much easier than targeting
people who don't so when you're at
somebody's wedding people spend stupid
money on weddings you know right people
people spend a lot of money on a lot of
things it's crazy right it's like they
want their dream wedding and they want
it to be perfect and and that's a great
business to be in
um it's it's much better than your other
idea like the the the low-income homes
is a noble idea but it's a hard first
business to do because you're you're
targeting people who don't have money
and so finding the the rental property
that will make you enough finding the
right quality tenants having people pay
you on time when they don't have any
money like it's going to be really hard
to make money in that business
not that you can't it's a it's a noble
ambition
but as a first business I would love to
see you
make some money again right so then you
can invest into other causes right
um You have to start thinking about what
what a good plan for your for your
wedding shop is going to be
and so
I would start talking all my all my
suppliers ask them how they're doing see
what they're up to
um I'd be sticking around in the
community like how did you get most of
your clients before Word of Mouth yeah
so see what happened was I had a
quinceanera
in 2015 my daughter turned 15. so it was
so hard for me to find her dress like
the perfect dress you know and just to
find everything that I wanted because it
was one sword in the area and they were
so basic you know and I wanted something
different so I did everything myself
never in my life have I done anything
like that so I did it myself and people
loved it and they were always asking me
like different people were asking me
where did you get it from you know like
or where did you buy the centerpieces
and I created everything yeah so that's
what started my business is nobody
calling you now for help yeah
and so what are you doing with them
they're calling you and saying hey I
need a dress or I need what's happening
right now right now I tell them I'm
sorry I'm closed um and I refer them
over to the lady that bought my stuff
do you have a non-compete
um no so why not say hey I'll make I'll
make your dress
well the address is what I was doing is
the dresses I was buying them and
reselling okay
so in order for me to do that I would
have to invest more money it's not
but what's the what's the order time on
address to get it in three months three
months that's a long time yeah well
what's it like this is the time to be
creative what can you do you've got
you've got customers coming like you've
got you've got the hard part
you got people who are calling you and
saying Hey how do I do this instead of
just passing them on to the person about
your store what what can you do to help
them like what did you do at the
beginning you didn't have so much
inventory and everything
well see this no this is what happened
because at the beginning I had what I
was doing was decorating venues because
that's I did that for my daughter too
and people wanted me to do what I did
for my daughter to do it for them
because it was so different so whenever
I sold that business I invested that
money
and I bought a bunch of merchandise
and then you started selling that and
then I started selling that instead of
me putting the work in I was just buying
and reselling
got it so so who can you connect with
that can make these dresses
faster or you can sell on commission
I could probably sell on commission
um but you see even that's what I guess
that's why I just decided to sell what I
had because it was just becoming so hard
for me because I didn't in order for me
to buy like
the big companies that sell the dresses
I have to buy
like
three thousand dollars
worth of dresses which is like three
dresses four dresses because those
dresses are really expensive but in
order for me to sell the dress then I
have to sell the bouquets
um
it's just a lot of stuff that comes with
it and people that buy your dresses they
want you to buy to sell them everything
like the bouquets the Tiaras
you know just like the whole I guess the
whole packages and that's where I was
making my money because I was selling
the whole packages but I was buying from
different suppliers
but the other stuff is fast flowers are
like flowers you know are you doing the
flowers in-house yourself no you work
with a flower shop
well it was more of um I wasn't doing
any real flowers I was doing fake
flowers okay great so but how long
what's the lead time on getting the
flowers together
um
it depends on what the person wants
sometimes two weeks three weeks so it's
not yeah it's faster like is anything as
long as the wedding dress
I guess it's not a wedding dress if
we're talking about 15 year old girls
right it's just like a uh like a special
party when you turn 15 it's a big deal
it's a it's a big deal
what yes wow this is the business you
need to be in I love it I love it and I
love talking 32 000 when she turned 15.
yes
is this only for girls or boys too girls
just it's just for girls when girls turn
15 it's a big deal okay
wow yeah
okay so so but the dress takes a lot of
time great but the other stuff is just a
matter of weeks
yeah
yeah so so then you could do all the
other stuff easily you can do all the
other stuff and see and that's how I
started because when I first started I
was doing everything from my house when
I got the permits I got them at my house
so it was like a home-based business
but then I just needed so much inventory
that I had to go out and rent a place
you know and that's what I'm thinking
okay so what if right now I focus on
taking a lot of courses towards
um e-commerce you know um knowing how to
use Instagram because this is the first
time I'm using Instagram now that I'm
you know in your yeah in your group
so just taking this time to train myself
to use YouTube channel to do Facebook
lives
um you know maybe just take like a whole
year and just learn how to do this other
stuff and then come back you know what I
mean like say this yeah I don't think
you need to though like I think you can
start right now like it's not that you
you shouldn't do Instagram or YouTube
will be able to blow this up and I think
you can even do it not just for your own
little not just for your own town not
just for North Carolina but you could do
it for America
you know and learning how can I Market
myself in in Florida right or in Texas
or in right but even for now you have an
opportunity like I want you
to be able to focus on this so you don't
have to have your job anymore like yeah
you could make enough just from your
current clients and and Word of Mouth
power right now you're just too attached
to like the store
people are still going to do their
parties they may not be 32 000 parties
forty two thousand how much did you
spend again oh my God I don't have
nightmares over this
if you have Justin Bieber come sing at
your Advent or something or what he
would do that he carried you more
um anyway like people are still doing
their parties they may not be as big
they may not be as expensive they may
not be as uh you know they may not be
having 100 people come over or whatever
with covet but they're still it's
obviously an important tradition and
people are still doing it just like
people are still having weddings and
Brides still want their wedding dress
and they still want their bouquets and
they still want their invitations and
all of this stuff right so maybe maybe
instead of a 32 000 party it's a fifteen
thousand dollar party or whatever but
they're still there's still room in
there for you to make money
there doesn't have to be a store for
people to go to the the thing that you
went off of was never actually your
store it's your heart
like you you you care about these
parties you care about these girls you
care about these families in a way that
probably the person took over your store
doesn't care as much about them it's not
that they don't care but it's a business
as opposed to something that's like deep
in our heart like whenever you start
talking about it you see your energy
come alive and you're happy and smiling
so I'll be looking right away How can I
make enough money from that business
so that I don't have to be at that job
and it may not be the same size business
as you had before yet once we get
through covet and all this and great it
can it can build up but you also don't
need it to be as big because you don't
have overhead you don't have a store to
have to go to and worry about and you
just have to be a little more
resourceful in that you can take
pictures of the things you know in your
home instead of them coming to to visit
your home maybe you order three dresses
that are kind of the most
common dress
that that is easier to sell compared to
like this crazy unique dress it's going
to be really hard to sell and you still
use all your suppliers because they
probably still love you
yeah it'd be happy and they're probably
stuck with
struggling business too and if you're
saying hey I've got an opportunity for
you maybe they give you a better rate or
maybe they give you faster timelines
because they want to keep their business
afloat too
if if I'm you I'm open for business I'm
at home and I'm open for business and I
can't do everything that I did before
but I'm but I still got the heart and I
still want to make sure that your
daughter has the greatest event of all
time and I'm the person who's going to
help you do that and here's how it can
help
okay
the only thing missing is just a lack of
belief that that path is possible so I
will you know I will think about it
because
I really don't want to give up on it you
know it's something that I love to do
and then I have another quinceanera
coming up in two years to have one more
daughter
you need fifty two thousand dollars
oh my God
this is amazing
um no you you you uh
the next person that calls you that says
Hey how do I Esmeralda I need address
who should I go to
me I'll help you okay the next people
who who call you say I'll help you
and then and then you put the word out
back to the like how will you
communicate with people just email or in
the Facebook group or just phone calls
or text or Facebook what like how are
you talking about phone calls and
Facebook I used to have a Facebook page
but I wasn't so good with it yeah listen
good at uploading with pictures but it
was that's fine no that's fine it's Word
of Mouth like this is a word of mouth
business You've Won because because you
have a big heart to do this
you're lovable people know that you're
going to do a good job and you've built
a reputation for for delivering right so
it's it's like today I would contact
look at the past 30 people who bought
from you and and call them and tell them
that you're you don't want to close down
the business and that you're open for
business from home
because the way it just spreads that
they know somebody who knows somebody
who knows somebody who knows somebody
and and it's they're gonna your phone's
gonna ring okay and I have one like I
have one quinceanera that they had a
postpone like
they had to postpone their party till
next year
so they want me to do it they want me to
do it so they're waiting for you know
they gave me a time but they want me to
do it of course and you're gonna say yes
I'm gonna do this not go to this person
who bought my store and so so yeah how
many do you need to do to not like how
many did you do in a month to not work
that job anymore
two two a month
oh my God come on this is what you need
to do just two I mean it's it's a really
good business and I guess that's what
drove me to do it because it's
I get to make money I get to talk to
teenagers which I love doing you know
when I I look I get to just come up with
new ideas because everybody wants
something different yeah and and so it
was like everything was there for me and
how many hours a week are you working at
this place
40 40 hours a week
like
you have to
you could get those too today
you could put out if you if you called
30 to 50 people today and just said hey
you know what I'm back in business I
don't have my store I'm doing it from
home I don't have all the resources that
I did before but
I will care more for your daughter and
your event than anybody else in this
city and if you know somebody or you're
doing it just keep me in mind
you'll get two
today
you just have to call 50 people
yeah and then you don't have to go
work 40 hours at a job
that
it's not that they're bad that the
company is bad but like you just you
know you can do so much more and you
don't have to wait three years for that
to happen and do real estate or anything
on the side until you get there like you
could make that happen today
what's the resistance to calling up all
the people who've worked with you who've
hired you in the past because people
know people and they have cousins and
nieces and you know second daughters and
all this other stuff right
what's the hesitation to just call in 50
people today who already know you in the
community and saying I'm open for
business if you know anybody I'm doing
it from home right now
I guess I'm just kind of
um I guess I was just depressed because
April came and I started getting phone
calls because what happens with these
parties is that they plan
ahead like a year ahead or six months
ahead just because it takes so long for
everything
for the whole planning
and I started getting calls look we need
to cancel I need a refund
um just one thing after the other
and on with some people I had to give
them a refund because I knew it wasn't
your fault you know so I'm I'm here not
making money and I have to give money
out and I guess it was just one thing
after the other you know my personal
life and then my business and
I just got the press and I was like this
is not me you know so I told myself I
can't keep doing this and I started
working that's the reason why I started
working because I was like I can't be at
home just feeling depressed
and now I'm like I mean do I really
I don't know like I just feel like I'm
not that same person you know that I
could do anything
no no you are you're not this person you
are that person you're that person
you're not this person this is who
you're not but it's just it's it's
listen a lot of people been punched in
the face because of covet and everything
else has happened right now a lot of a
lot of people and and that is part of
business you know stuff is going to
happen this is obviously a crazy time
totally outside your control nobody
predicted that this was coming
um and it's like just imagine where you
want to be in three years that's that's
possible you can have a bigger store
than you had before
and people still like this is part of
the culture and the Heritage and people
are still going to have like unless
people stop having daughters or
something you know like there's always
going to be a business for you
[Music]
with your heart and care and yes
learning about Instagram and YouTube
might help you turn this into a national
thing where now you're getting orders
from from Miami and getting orders from
from Dallas right like you can orders
from across America and work with people
but you could easily get back to a place
where you can support yourself not have
to have that job get your two two
clients a month
just by putting the word out to the 50
people and if they say hey we're still
uh we're still not ready like
October next year we'll do it or June
next to it okay no problem whenever
you're ready I'm here
and if you want to do it when your
daughter is 16 years old I'm I'm ready
for that too right yeah
it's a little bit of
um humbleness you know to
it feels like a failure going backwards
and it's but but look at what's happened
instead you've gone and got a job at a
retail store instead
right
I would I would call like I think you
can get your 50 your two clients
today by calling up to 50 people
and again they may not be as profitable
and you don't have your store and all
that stuff but you can still get that
business today
and you can start to this is all all
this is is just how how long do we want
to stay in the hole because he got hit
hard like a lot of you know the world
did and you're in the hole right now but
you can get out a lot faster than most
people
you can get out just how long do you
want to stay here before you get out and
in your head is like okay I'm gonna wait
three years here and then do real estate
and then build my store bigger whereas
like that could happen
way faster
if you wanted to
and it's just giving yourself permission
to to do it
and call the clients and it's okay that
you took this little
uh I almost got a pity party but like
the little time to reflect and and
don't judge yourself too hard for not
being perfect and not
um
not being on schedule and sticking to
your routine and being like the the
ambitious person that you used to be
that's who you actually are this is just
a slow period like it's a small setback
which happens right this isn't just
straight up right it's a lot of this so
you're in a down just you can control
how low you stay down here and you know
I desperately want you just to call 50
people today
or maybe you're not working tomorrow
because you just got two deals from the
50 calls that you made today possibly
hopefully and listen even if you don't
get the even if you don't get the two
sales right now
uh just saying that you're back in it
and you want to help people from your
home
uh we'll get you a deal we'll get you to
two deals next month like if you don't
get it today you'll get it next month
and that that that allows you to have a
a window for your job so that it's not
40 hours working for somebody else doing
work that you hate for years it's for
the next couple weeks because you still
got to make money you still got to get
paid to just mortgage all that stuff
um but just letting people know that
you're back you will get deals
and it's just accepting smaller deals
and building up it would be like going
back whenever I first started you know I
was just doing them because people were
asking me to do important not because I
I wasn't planning on on starting a
business yeah I was just first I started
doing it for free with friends and
family and then it became a business so
and you're a lot smarter than you were
then and you have a lot more connections
than you did than you did back then and
you know how to solve problems way
faster than you did back then so you can
rebuild like if my YouTube channel went
to zero I could rebuild a lot faster
than the 11 years it took me to get here
so same thing with you like even if
you're starting you're not actually
starting from scratch it's not like
you're moving to a brand new city
and have no idea what you're doing like
you already have connections and
suppliers and people who love you and
know you and want to work with you
you can rebuild it way way faster but
it's not going to happen if you don't
make the calls and it's not going to
happen if you are staying at this job
that you don't like
sure
that's true let's go Esmeralda come on
it's 50 calls
yeah yeah
make the calls
you just got to make the calls
will do all right I'll talk to you
tomorrow Esmeralda all right
all right thank you
to see me coach another entrepreneur one
on one check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there promo tip
which I got from uh Tony Robbins that
can help you whenever you're talking
about the book you hold it up but it's
great that you have it as a prop right
and you got in the background too you
never say this book or my book you say
the name of the book so people remember
the book